[Musique]
avec moi sur ce plateau mélanie poquet
bonsoir on ça décidément vous venez tous
les jours sur ce plateau alors après
l'environnement le sport et la musique
c'est l'espace qui est à l'honneur cette
année le festival saint quentin le fil
le festival du film documentaire de
notre chaîne tv 78 revient pour sa
quatrième édition mélanie pots cassés
votre coup de coeur de la semaine
tel est le programme la première la
première date à noter dans vos agendas
c'est la soirée d'ouverture elle se
passa dgc skywest à partir de 19h30 ce
soir la sarre enregistré une édition
spéciale du peuple émission de patrice
carmouze
il aura autour de lui quatre invités
donc deux chercheuses lune du latmos
l'autre du cnrs
l'entrée est gratuite il faut juste
s'inscrire sur le site du festival
3w 50-1 point fr on rappelle cet
important c'est avant tout un festival
du film documentaire
et oui cette année huit films sont en
compétition grégory huit documentaires
qui vont vous emmener la tête dans les
étoiles vous découvrirez des projets
d'observatoire toujours plus grand pour
être servi les étoiles la formation des
futurs grands pilotes français est bien
sûr une aventure qui a passionné des
milliers de personnes le voyage de
thomas pesquet le dernier spationaute
français avoir été dans l'espace et un
objectif de montrer que ce qui vient de
l'espace nous touchent au quotidien
beaucoup des progrès scientifiques la
téléphonie mobile les travaux sur les
small size par exemple sont directement
dérivés y compris des travaux d'apollo
de l'époque
est ce qu'il faut dire c'est ce choix du
thème de l'espace n'est pas anodin pour
saint quentin en yvelines
savez-vous pas mais sur le territoire
des yvelines de l'agglomération
enregistrés régulièrement les étoiles de
grands entreprises travaillent dans cet
univers airbus thales dassault mais
aussi des laboratoires
il nous semblait logique de travailler
sur cet espace qui est bien génère
beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois sur le
bassin de 50 ans les villes ça c'est
pour la partie j'allais dire purement
économique mais également on est tous
des petits garçons et petites filles qui
avons dès notre plus jeune âge lever les
yeux pour regarder à vue
ont levé les yeux pour regarder les
fusées et donc ça parle au grand public
sa part à nous tous alors allez sur
plusieurs prix vont être remis le prix
tv 78 celui de troisième celui des
cinémas et les spectateurs ont aussi
leur mot à dire avec le prix du public
en plus des documentaires des films sont
aussi diffusées chez les cinémas
partenaires du célèbre stanley kubrick
2001 l'odyssée de l'espace son tout
dernier damien chazelle forsman qui
parle de neil armstrong laissez vous
tenter et grégory laissez vous révéliez
de quoi effectivement et à l'occasion de
la soirée d'ouverture de ce festival
saint quentin tv 78 délocalise son
plateau à l'ugc de skywest demain 18
heures retrouvez nous en direct depuis
le centre commercial saint quentinois
pour instituer du journal spécial où
nous parlerons largement de l'événement
à partir de 19h30 patrice carmouze prend
le relais avec ses invités pour son
émission paf
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans un
instant pour le 7-8 culture c'est dans
un instant après une page de pub